feel that chill it's not the end of
summer it's the start of a Halloween
season netflix already features a huge
lineup of horror titles primed for a
Halloween binge session but the service
is also loading up on brand new horror
here are the scariest new releases
hitting Netflix this October creeped out
season 1 this horror themed
co-production between Netflix and the
BBC may come across as a black mirror
for kids but well okay on second thought
that's exactly what this is as an
anthology series each episode tells its
own bite-sized Horror Story with
different characters and different
settings the twist is that all the
stories are connected by a creepy masked
man who is out to collect mankind's
darkest tales the episodes explore
everything from psychological horror to
the supernatural preying on your darkest
fears and giving you plenty of reasons
to sleep with the lights on the first
season of creeped out debuted on BBC in
2017 but October 4th will mark the first
time the series is available for an
international audience
malevolent here's an interesting twist
on the haunted house genre malevolence
follows a brother and sister scam artist
duo who trick people into thinking their
houses are haunted then go in and
pretend to drive the ghost away
business is booming until they run into
an actual haunted house and discover
that real ghosts are a lot more
dangerous than the fake ones look for it
October 5th apostle Gareth Evans is best
known in the film world for writing and
directing the action-packed martial arts
film the raid and its sequel the raid 2
but with apostle Evans is making a
departure from his usual action fare and
taking a deep dive into cult based
horror at the turn of the 20th century a
sadistic cult kidnaps a young woman and
takes her to their remote island for
culty purposes what they didn't count on
was the woman's brother coming after her
if the trailer is any indication that's
just the start of the mayhem you can
expect from apostle strapped in on
October 12th the haunting of Hill House
season 1 get ready for all the horror
you can stomach with a haunting of Hill
House based on the classic novel by
Shirley Jackson the series stars carla
Gugino and Michiel Huisman
and centers on a family that came back
to the haunted house where they grew up
the haunting of Hill House comes from
Mike Flanagan who
recently been making waves in the horror
world with Netflix Gerald's game and his
under-the-radar horror gems oculus and
hush look for the first season of the
haunting of Hill House the hit Netflix
on October 12 haunted season 1
if fiction isn't your speed this
Halloween fear not
Netflix is also bringing in a horror
series based on true events well sort of
haunted sits down with people who claim
to have first-hand accounts of
paranormal experiences ghosts aliens
monsters in the night it's all here and
the series will recreate these stories
and terrifying detail fleshing out the
horror in imaginative new ways part true
terror and part cinematic creep fest
haunted is bound to offer plenty of
reasons to sit in front of the TV all
day tune in when season one drops
October 19th
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina maybe
you want a horror tinged version of the
late 90s sitcom Sabrina the Teenage
Witch or maybe you dig those teenage
torn dogs and Riverdale but you want
more pacts with the devil well good news
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina puts
the classic Archie comics character
smack dab in the middle of a battle
against evil according to Entertainment
Weekly the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina was originally meant to act as a
sister series to Riverdale once
production moved over to Netflix however
the idea of bridging the two shows was
put on the back burner it's still
possible but for now the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina stands completely
on its own take a look when it arrives
on October 26th Castlevania Season 2 the
first season of Netflix hyper-violent
Castlevania adaptation came out of the
gates with Mitylene reviews but quickly
built up a large fan following the story
follows Trevor Belmont the protagonist
of Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse as he
battles the supernatural forces of
Dracula today join us sure by the way
you're all going to die
by all accounts season 2 will pick up
right where the first season left off
drawing viewers further into the
horrifying world at 15th century while a
Kea with horror and action in equal
measure
Castlevania makes the perfect show to
binge on this Halloween season if you
haven't caught the first season yet
you'll have plenty of time to catch up
before season 2 lands on October 26th
new thriller movie
while Netflix will be putting on their
usual selection of films and shows from
all genres Halloween calls for a special
focus on the horror based titles from
horror classic The Shining arriving on
the first to the exorcism of Molly
Hartley which hits Netflix on the 4th
there's a lot of new stuff on the way
and while they aren't pure horror
Stephen King's supernatural drama The
Green Mile and the first two films in
the Blade trilogy also arrive on the
first what better time than Halloween to
relive those classics is always trying
to ice-skate of him
Oh blade we missed you